we often think of the economy as a
straight line we work hard to produce a
lot so we can consume or increase our
gains and spend it all again but where
does this take us our society and our
planet what if what if the economy was
not a straight line but more like a web
like a beautiful spider web without the
spider of those four different lines
representing values such as innovation
education equality health that come
together to make like like an economy of
well-being that's the word must remember
it's the economy of well-being it's
based on a simple idea that our
well-being makes a reconning grow and
the other way around in this economy
success is not only measured in terms of
productivity in the games but also in
terms of happiness physical and mental
health of citizens sustainability so we
invest in people's well-being and they
are healthier more innovative and
productive and they work and pay taxes
without feeling too bad about it because
the money they pay is used to improve
their well-being and work is not the
only thing people enjoy their work of
course but they also have time for
friends and family men and women are
more equal and you don't need to come
from a rich family to get into
university or to become a famous
scientist and we're not destroying our
planets because we finally realize that
it's the only one we have so we're
taking care of it sounds great does
but how do we come to this economy I'm
not sure I have the answer maybe we just
need to start thinking differently so
let's erase the straight line and look
beyond the market beyond averages beyond
the here and now and into the future
let's start building an economy of
well-being
the end
[Music]